- I have a sneaky feeling
we're going to be late.
So I got to, we got to rush.
- I hope we win.
- [Evan] You hope we win?
Me too, you think they're going to win?
Yeah?
- They're already at three.
- Oh!
- Alright, let's see it.
Go Jays go.
Good morning!
Welcome to day two!
- Bluejays game!
- [Evan] Bluejay game day!
♫ Tomorrow is Disney World
- But more exciting than Disney World is
Bluejay game day today!
- He's wrong.
- [Evan] Hayden's eating,
what are you eating?
- [Hayden] Hotdog.
- Hotdog and Cheerios?
I support it.
Stephanie and Jeffrey are
eating hotdogs and eggs.
- And we're watching TV.
- Eat a yummy breakfast, and
then head off to the game,
so we are not late!
I'm excited.
So we have a, history of being late
for the Bluejays game,
mostly because of Florida traffic.
The GPS says it's going to take
an hour and a half to get there
and it takes us like three, so
the first two years we were late,
the third year we got there
just as it was starting,
and this is our fourth year.
I have a sneaky feeling
we're going to be late,
so I got to, we got to rush.
We got to rush!
Let's go, get some Starbucks,
and rush, rush, rush.
To the baseball game!
(smooth Latin music)
Nina is in bad need of--
- Coffee.
And there's only one
Starbucks between here and
where we're going.
So, we stop here every year
for the fourth year in a row, to get
a coffee for the Nina!
- Ow, you just stepped on me!
- Oh, you okay?
- Yeah, no,
it hurt.
- We're celebrating love though?
- Uh-huh.
- Okay, yeah, let's go get some coffee!
(upbeat piano music)
We got our coffee.
Nina got a--
- Coffee.
- Grande Pike.
She's very excited about it.
- They don't have milk.
Who doesn't use milk?
I don't like cream.
- Nina doesn't like cream, Starbucks.
Evan got a venti caramel machiatto.
Cheers.
Mm.
Holy cow, it's strong.
I'm not used to this.
(Evan laughs)
- Really, is it strong?
It's not strong.
- Back in the car, let's go
go go to the baseball game!
(upbeat piano music)
We stopped in quickly,
for lunch at Chick-fil-A.
So we got to hustle.
Nina got chicken fingers,
- I got chicken fingers.
- [Evan] We basically
all got chicken fingers.
And I got a chicken burger.
And we got to leave in five minutes
to get to the baseball game.
Whatever you don't finish, you're bringing
in the car.
- Go Bluejays!
- Alright, we made it, we
parked, we're on our way in.
What's Nina doing, are you vlogging this?
- No, I'm just taking a picture.
- Oh, Nina's taking a picture
- Oh my god.
Picture!
- Okay!
Everybody get in!
Okay, who's going to win today?
- [Kids] The Bluejays!
- Let's hope, right?
Let's hope, let's see it.
Nina's worried that it's going to rain.
- It's raining.
- [Evan] What are you going to, oh no!
No rain, no rain.
Look at those clear skies, that's amazing.
It's all sunny up there.
Beautiful Florida sunshine, right Nina?
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
That wasn't a rain drop, that was just,
love juice from the sky!
- Are they going to put
the roof up, it's raining.
- [Evan] There's no roof here.
- Oh.
- This isn't Toronto.
Yeah, if it rains, you get wet.
(country rock music)
- So Nina did a weather check, and--
- It's going to shower at--
- Huh?
- Four p.m.
They're starting, we're still in line.
So, we might get rained on.
It's okay, a little Florida rain.
We got this.
I want to be inside!
- Now!
(upbeat electronica music)
- What happened Nina?
- Ugh, they won't let me
bring in the selfie stick.
- Nina's not happy.
- No.
- They won't let her
bring in her selfie stick.
It looked like a weapon, Nina's--
- How is it like a weapon?
- You can be violent at times, so,
- Oh, did you just drop on me?
- No.
Did I just drop on you? (laughs)
It's this beautiful sunny weather here.
Nina threw the selfie stick in a bush.
- Yeah.
- Who's going to go find
it after this? (laughs)
(playful music)
- Look at Hayden's shirt.
Choose your weapon.
Which is your favorite weapon?
- My favorite weapon?
If you could make up your powers,
then my favorite weapon is this one.
- Emerald.
- 'Cause it could
shoot emeralds, and then when
it hits something it breaks
and sends green spirits everywhere.
- Sounds pretty powerful.
- And they--
- Nice.
- And they give you a curse.
- Oh, wow.
Sounds pretty dangerous.
What are you guys having?
- A twist!
- [Evan] It's an ice cream break.
How is it?
- It's good.
- [Cashier] There you go.
- And one for Stephanie, okay, thank you!
Okay, let's go back.
What do we think, guys?
- Yum!
- Good!
How is it Jeffrey?
- Good.
- Alright, good.
Let's get back to our seats,
Jays are winning, yeah.
- I hope we win.
- [Evan] You hope we win?
Me too, you think they're going to win?
Yeah?
- They're already at three.
- Oh!
- Alright, let's see it.
Go Jays go.
(energetic music)
- Bluejays won, now we
got to see if we can get
Nina's selfie stick that
she threw in the bush.
Let's see how we do.
Oh, looks like it's gone.
No selfie stick, we'll
have to buy a new one.
But at least the Jays won.
Time to go home.
Drive in the rain, get some food,
Finish the day.
(energetic music)
- I got so hungry that I forgot to film
and let you guys know what we're eating!
Nina made some awesome food,
look at those pork chops.
And some special pasta.
Spinach and pasta and
carrots and mushrooms and--
- Oh!
- [Evan] Oh, it's Hayden!
Holy crap.
Eating is good.
Yeah.
(mellow electronica music)
It's the end of day two.
Again we kind of forgot to film,
What are you doing, you
looking at yourself?
- Yeah.
- We forgot to film after
dinner, what did we do?
We cleaned up.
- You cleaned up.
- I cleaned up, I put the kids to bed.
- Yeah.
- I gave them a bath.
- They gave them their bath.
They gave each other bath.
- Well, I helped.
And I've been researching the
health benefits of green tea.
(laughs)
I kind of went down this
rabbit hole tonight about
researching green tea, and the benefits,
and how to determine a good
green tea versus a bad one.
So--
- We have a lot of
leafy tea at home.
- I'll be looking at different
green teas when I get back.
- My skin looks very--
- What?
- Glossy, and--
- Glossy?
- And very good.
- I married a glossy Chinese person.
- Look at the, look at the screen.
- You're shiny.
- Yeah, my skin look very shiny.
- Nina shines in all situations.
Goodbye all, have a great night.
Thank you for joining us for day two.
Tomorrow we start off
at Disney, day three,
by hitting up...
- Continue to believe!
- Epcot.
(both laugh)
Epcot, continue to believe?
- Whatever you want where it is,
we'll see you next time.
- Bye!